plus de 300 collégiens dansant le
breakdance spectacle que vous avez
peut-être aperçu tout à l'heure si vous
étiez du côté de la gare de Tours aux
côtés des jeunes danseurs cet après-midi
un invité de marque on la personne de
Sydney l'animateur télé qui a popularisé
le hip-hop dans les têtes Paris 2024 ou
le breakdance fera ses premiers pas
comme disciplines olympique le reportage
de Sarah gros
on ne s'en doute pas pourtant ces 300
collégiens s'apprêtent à danser sur le
parvis de la gare ils ont travaillé une
chorégraphie de breakdance qu'ils
interprètent sur trois lieux différents
ce mercredi une journée qu'ils
attendaient avec impatience on a fait
beaucoup d'efforts et d'arriver là
aujourd'hui bah c'est quand même bien
c'est un sport qui permet d'extérioriser
enfin je trouve parce que je peux parler
en faisant de la danse c'est un peu de
musique
ou exetera tu peux danser ça quand tu
t'exprimes
[Musique]
la chorégraphie collective a été
imaginée par Simon dimourot pendant un
an il a accompagné les six collèges sur
trois séances de deux heures
rester sur des choses assez simples
c'est à dire qu'ils font tous la même
chose au même moment parce que partir
dans des choses un peu différé ou trop
complexes à être trop compliqué pour
pour 300 élèves le clou du spectacle un
invité un peu spécial l'animateur de
l'émission phare de hip-hop dans les
années 80 n'a pas manqué à la pelle
Sydney était présent pour encourager les
élèves pour lui plus qu'une discipline
le hip-hop est aujourd'hui devenu une
culture
on détient il y a un côté banlieue il y
a un côté non maintenant que le hip-hop
est intégré dans tous les milieux
sociaux que ce soit des bourgeois que ce
soit les pauvres c'est un milieu c'est
une culture qui rassemble maintenant ne
fait que évoluer parce que les gens
commencent à reconnaître
qu'effectivement c'est une culture à
part entière avant c'était pas le cas
une évolution loin d'être négligeable en
2024 le hip-hop fera son entrée aux Jeux
olympiques de Paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]